our shadow tonight goes to a dogged
reporter in the San Francisco Bay Area
whose work has helped to uncover what
really happened in several deadly fires
showing they probably could have and
should have been prevented
just last year in 2018 there was the
state's deadliest and most destructive
fire the campfire reporter Matthias
Gaffney known as T in the newsroom was
determined to find out the story of what
happened using a database that archives
police and fire frequencies and I just
started listening right around the time
that they believe the fire started and
sure enough I heard that a dispatcher
get a call okay cross under the
high-tech power lines there's a possible
power line hazard and they basically
reported that there were wires down
underneath transmission lines
and this is right at the moment that the
campfires believed was started and right
in the area that the campfire was
believed to have started 1026 is falling
apart right down so that was a real big
break in finding out what may be the
cause for this fire the evidence
pointing to the state giant PG&E utility
key Genie just now I said that they are
probably at fault with their equipment
having a malfunction and so that was you
know just a few days after the camp fire
that we were able to narrow that down
and and show that PG&E very well could
be at fault and beyond the equipment
malfunction Gaffney determined that PG&E
if it followed its own guidelines should
have shut down the power in such high
risk fire conditions most of those
criteria were actually met prior to the
camp fire yet for some reason they
decided to keep the power on PG&E now
has declared bankruptcy saying it
expects to face massive lawsuits two
years earlier in another deadly fire
Gaffney was just as adept in disproving
the notion that city officials in
Oakland were unaware of potentially
dangerous conditions at a huge warehouse
called the ship where dozens of artists
and musicians had taken up residence we
wound up getting and we found that
police officers routinely were
responding there and when they responded
there we found a couple things out from
their body cam footage one was that the
the lead tenant of that warehouse was
saying that no one lived inside the the
warehouse which was not true and then
but we also found that in one instance
two police officers respond to a call
for service and you see them walking
through this maze inside the warehouse
and you can hear one of the officers say
something to the effect of all would
take is one match in this place would go
up
thirty-six people died in the fire two
of the buildings principle tenants have
been charged criminally in both the city
and the Landlord are facing huge
lawsuits Gaffney's reporting on the ship
fire earned him and his fellow reporters
a Pulitzer Prize and two weeks ago he
joined the San Francisco Chronicle after
being named the journalist of the year
in Northern California by the Society of
Professional Journalists I'm born and
raised in the Bay Area here and I have a
you know family I find it really
impactful to kind of do reporting that
immediately impacts my community and you
know the people I've grown up with and I
love and respect so it's really pretty
rewarding so our shout-out tonight to
Matthias Gaffney that's our program
thanks for joining us good night